[Music]
on this Tuesday night fast tracking
solutions for medical supplies thousands
of Canadian companies raced to refocus
what Sun crusted enters is the speed and
thousands of defective face masks are
recalled the British Prime Minister
spends another night in the ICU he's a
fighter and he'll be back his prognosis
as Britain's death toll soars New York's
deadliest day of the pandemic could that
city have reached a turning point giving
a possible gift of life human clinical
trials underway using blood plasma from
co-lead 19 survivors and the pressure on
Canada's caregivers it just adds to the
installation unsung heroes in uncertain
times what happens if we both get her
[Music]
warble national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we want to start with some promising
news tonight the federal government says
is it has made lots of progress on
getting much needed personal protection
equipment for frontline workers and the
strategy is very much made in Canada
nearly 5,000 companies were told across
the country have offered to retool to
make medical supplies an auto parts
company for example is using airbag
material to make hospital gowns other
companies have struck a deal to make up
to 30,000 ventilators it's all part of
Ottawa's plan to buy buy buy and build
build build until the medical system has
what it needs
we have told these companies across the
country who put up their hands to go
ahead and get building ventilators as
quickly as possible and as many as
possible in case we need them in Canada
we certainly hope that we won't be
needing all those ventilators the
government is buying supplies from
overseas - gloves gowns and masks in a
market that's described as like the Wild
West
countries are all competing for the same
dwindling pool of products so far the
federal government says it's sourced
more than 230 million surgical masks
over 16 million it says have already
been delivered in our top story tonight
Michael Couture looks at the Canadian
companies that have taken up the call to
help
it was a lifesaver in the 2003 SARS
outbreak and an updated version of the
Winnipeg ventilator could help thousands
of Canadians survive covet 19 the
Canadian made ventilator is being
retooled by a cluster of companies
including starfish medical that hope to
accomplish the Herculean effort of
making thousands of these in a short
timeframe normally something like this
would take two or three years and we're
compressing it into weeks to months
we're hoping that we'll get through all
of our clinical testing that we need to
do and regulatory during me and then
we'll be manufacturing as soon as we can
at the same time the Prime Minister has
tapped Nobel Prize winner dr. art
McDonald to fast-track his easy to make
ventilator which will be tested in Italy
we hope to get medical medical
certification there we've been working
closely with the FDA in the US and
Health Canada we expect to be able to
produce these objects starting in a few
weeks time the federal government has
ordered 30,000 ventilators even though
Canada may not need that many but if we
don't Prime Minister Justin Trudeau says
they won't go to waste and we will have
ventilators to share with other
countries that are facing more difficult
circumstances for us doing more right
now doing quicker right now is really
the only option manufacturers like
Canada Goose and Stan fields are now
retooling their operations to make
medical gowns for frontline health care
workers the government is also in talks
with nearly 5,000 Canadian companies to
make personal protective equipment so we
don't have to rely on buying it from
other countries because supplies are so
scarce ordering of course does not
guarantee a delivery the lack of PPE s
has frontline workers worried will run
out and the nurses union is appealing to
citizens who are now wearing masks you
see somebody from the public wearing a
surgical or an n95 they don't belong on
the street they belong in our healthcare
system there's a huge rush to get all of
this equipment but faster isn't always
better the City of Toronto to recall
about $200,000 worth of surgical masks
citing poor quality and those masks were
sent to long-term care homes where the
need is even more acute Donna all right
Mike look at or in Ottawa thanks the
premier of Alberta says his province is
facing a triple threat kovat 19 and the
collapse of the economy and of energy
prices Jason Kenney released to disease
models tonight he said the probable
scenario is that infections will peak in
mid-may and that there would be between
400 and 3,100 deaths in Alberta and this
he says is the elevated scenario under
the most serious but less likely
elevated scenario we would see
infections peak at the beginning of May
a with as much with as many as 1 million
infections and between 500 and 6600
deaths but these models are not a done
deal
I want Albertans instead to see them as
a challenge perhaps the greatest
challenge of our generation Renier Kenny
says restrictions like physical
distancing will not be relaxed until the
end of May and he plans to ramp up an
aggressive system of mass testing and do
as many as 20,000 tests a day here are
the number of cases in Canada right now
more than 17,000 people have tested
positive for kovat 19 more than 1,200
new cases were reported today Ontario
and Quebec had the biggest daily
increase in new cases Ontario confirmed
379 more cases Quebec reported 760 more
people tested positive but NBC there
were only 25 new lab confirmed cases
that's the lowest daily increase that
province has reported in weeks and some
breaking news from Ottawa tonight the
deputy minister of global affairs Marta
Morgan has tested positive for kovat 19
the government says her symptoms are
mild and she is now self isolating the
numbers across Canada don't affect the
whole story of course we took because
testing is still limited in Canada and
it's still too early to be certain of
anything but there are signs the overall
curve in Canada is showing signs of
flattening especially in BC
one of the biggest concerns everywhere
are outbreaks in long-term care
facilities there are at least 51
outbreaks and homes in Ontario alone
Eric Sorenson is analyzing the data
gained for us tonight unquestionably
Quebec has been the hardest hit province
now a long-term care facility in Laval
may have one of the worst kovat 19
outbreaks in the country 105 residents
have tested positive eight have died as
of today in Quebec 150 have died from
the corona virus the province is
projecting the number could be over 1200
by the end of April in a worst case
scenario
more than 8800 but officials do say
Quebec is on course to handle the
outbreak so far the Premier says this is
a critical week to contain the spread
there must be no gatherings including
for religious celebrations such as
Easter sound advice for the nation as
hard hit as Quebec is the Premier says
the province is heading in the right
direction we're making progress in our
battle against the virus and so is the
country making progress the number of
kovat 19 cases in Canada continues to
rise but there has been an improvement
in the daily numbers after a sharp rise
to over 1,200 cases on one day last week
the numbers began to flatten out a
little bit in fact there were fewer than
1,200 yesterday British Columbia stands
out no longer a sharp rise in the total
numbers and look at the daily cases for
one week last week BC had an average of
71 new cases per day but this past week
just 42 new cases per day a distinct
downward trend all of Canada is ahead of
early infection forecasts typically this
virus is doubling every every few days
and we've definitely seen a slowdown in
that we're still seeing increases in
cases but they're not increasing nearly
as fast what happened a dramatic change
in behavior everywhere Google
geo-located the movement of Canadians
last month
public transit hubs usage down
two-thirds a plunge in retail shopping
restaurants movies many just closed up a
big drop in going to our usual
workplaces instead working from home
even grocery and pharmacy Canadians are
going but less often
a steady falling off and visiting parks
as we keep our distance and the one
upturn of course residential as we spend
more time at home because we some people
come together March 31st and stay at
home we should start to see the effects
of that now in the second half of April
grim mortality numbers still lie ahead
for this country but by all indications
the main approach staying away from
other people appears to have been the
right strategy if we can keep it up Erik
Sorensen Global News Toronto it is
situation critical in the UK tonight
Prime Minister Boris Johnson is spending
a second night in intensive care
battling kovat 19:00 and the UK recorded
its highest daily death toll so far 786
people died in 24 hours Christel go man
singh has an update on Johnson's
condition in the middle of a crushing
financial and health crisis Britons are
deprived of their bombastic leader it is
quite worrying for for the country for
people in general because what's going
to happen he's the leader right for the
country and my thoughts are with him and
his family because obviously it's very
worrying time for them Boris Johnson
remains in the ICU he said to be stable
breathing on his own but has required
oxygen the designate Dominic Raab tried
to calm fears saying here's no doubt
Johnson will be back soon but he didn't
shy away from the emotion of all of it
it comes as a shock to all of us he's
not just the prime minister for all of
us in cabinet he's not just our boss
he's also a colleague and he's also our
friend the cabinet works closely
literally this photo from inside Downing
Street was taken in February social
distancing had been applied but in the
early days so much time was spent
working shoulder-to-shoulder
a number of government officials have
been infected or showed symptoms UK
hospital admissions are rising as our
deaths
Tuesday saw the highest daily death toll
so far Cobin 19 has claimed more than
6,000 lives with so much uncertainty
solace from the Queen she reached out to
Johnson's pregnant fiance and his family
sharing her well wishes for everyone to
see crystal de Manson Global News London
there was some hope Spain had reached a
plateau the number of deaths had been
dropping for four days but today it rose
again there were seven hundred and forty
three deaths in Spain in 24 hours that
is 100 more than Monday and more than
5000 confirmed new cases were recorded a
rise of more than a thousand Spain has
the second highest number of confirmed
confirmed cases of CO vid 19 the US as
the most in France more than 10,000
people are now known to have died from
the virus and officials their war in the
country has not reached the peak of the
pandemic more than 1400 new deaths were
recorded in France overnight that's the
biggest single-day increase in the world
though the number of new cases did drop
lockdown measures were tightened today
all outdoor sports activities between 10
a.m. and 7 p.m. and France have been
banned and police are switching to foot
patrols and using unmarked vehicles to
enforce the rules
officials in New York State believe they
are close to possibly reaching the apex
of the outbreak though today was the
single deadliest day of the pandemic
there at least 731 people died in New
York State in 24 hours but fewer people
are being sent to intensive care and
being put on ventilators as Jackson
prosecco explains thousands more are
still expected to die New York's darkest
day yet brought wave after wave of death
and no relief for overburdened hospitals
funeral homes can't keep up with the
endless cycle of grief
we're over whelmed overwhelmed we might
make my staffers there on would send
every victim has a story and across the
u.s. those stories involve people of all
ages from all walks of life all taken by
the virus from this medicine EMTs
in the surge officials see small signs
of hope in New York the number of people
hospitalized increased only slightly in
the last day fewer people are being sent
to the ICU have you seen anything in
recent days that makes you optimistic I
don't see a lot of cause for optimism
dr. Peter Hotez warns that even if the
curve is starting to flatten there still
a long grim road ahead I likened it to
the eye of a hurricane where just
because you're seeing the eye you have
to remember the other half is still to
come so there's still gonna be a lot of
serious illness and death even if they
have plateaued
the peak has come on faster the rate of
deaths higher than expected the
scientists whose models forecast more
than 100 thousand fatalities in the u.s.
say social distancing has helped but it
has to keep going we are seeing that
people are staying at home that are
hidden to dismiss urges and that it's
less mortality and it's gonna go down
faster as long as we maintain these
measures of social distancing and that
is the question here how quickly do
those case numbers start to drop off
once they reach their eventual peak the
experience in other countries is that it
has been a very long slow and painful
descent from the top Donna all right
Jackson Prosecco in Washington thanks
Tokyo now under a state of emergency
coming up what more than nine million
Japanese are being asked to do tonight
Japan declared a state of emergency
today for Tokyo and its surrounding
regions after a surgeon confirmed cases
of kovat 19 it's not a lockdown it's a
request for people to stay home and
there are no penalties for violating it
the measures are being criticized it's
coming too late
Japan has almost 4,000 confirmed cases
of kovat 19 and close to 100 people have
died China reached a milestone today
according to official figures no new
deaths from Kovach 19 were reported that
hasn't happened since January and after
76 days have locked down the city of
Wuhan where this pandemic started has
been liberated residents were allowed to
leave the city and go to work there have
been two new cases of Kovan 19 in the
last 14 days China had more than 80 1000
confirmed cases and over 3,300 deaths
Russia is reporting its largest one-day
spike in cases more than 1,100 people
have been tested positive in the past 24
hours
officials say 58 people have died from
Kobe 19 in Russia and there are almost
7,500 people believed to be infected
many regions in the country are under
lockdown Moscow is hardest hit
clinical trials ahead how Kovach 19
survivors may be able to save lives
you are watching global national
[Music]
India's government is lifting export
restrictions on an anti-malarial drug
that the American president has said
could be a cure for kovat 19 even though
there's no scientific evidence to back
that up India is the largest producer of
hydroxychloroquine the Indian government
had banned exports of the drug to
protect domestic stocks but Prime
Minister Narendra Modi eased those
restrictions under direct threat of
retaliation from President Trump the
drug is being tested but it has not been
proven as an effective treatment for
Kovach 19 Canadian patients are now part
of a human clinical trial of an
experimental potential treatment for
kovat 19 it involves giving antibody
rich blood plasma from people who have
recovered to patients who are still
infected Heather Eurex West explains the
theory and the trial as Canada's
hospitals brace for the coming wave of
new coronavirus patients those who have
already survived kovat 19 will soon be
called upon to help we're reaching out
to public health to actually get lists
of patients who they have defined as
recovered from Cobra 19 and we will be
inviting those those people to
participate as as plasma donors people
like Karen shoemaker the 74 year-old
spent several days in hospital last
month but she's now out of isolation and
doing much better
researchers believe her blood is now
filled with antibodies that know exactly
how to attack and stop the virus that
causes cough at 19 you can't say you
were fortunate to have it but we're
fortunate that we healed and if we've
got some antibodies that can somehow be
check to see if they can prevent other
people from getting it or even help
people who currently have it why
wouldn't you share using donated blood
as a therapy is not a new idea
convalescent plasma has been used for
more than 100 years with varying amounts
of success the data that we've got to go
on is is really really soft right now
it's very hard to say if this actually
works there's good biological rationale
to think that it might but we just don't
know it's why a team of researchers from
the universities of Montreal Toronto and
McMahon
stur are racing to set up a major
Canadian clinical trial partnering with
Canadian Blood Services and Hema Quebec
to collect donations from 1000 kovat 19
survivors there are so many moving parts
we need to ensure that we have a supply
of this product from eligible donors at
the same time we want this to happen
quickly because the peak of demand for
patients who are going to be in hospital
with acute kovat infection is going to
happen in the next few weeks shoemaker
says she's willing to help at any time
hopeful that whatever is now in her
blood could be enough to save lives
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
Canada's caregivers next recognizing the
quiet loving work they do each day
you
we know many of you across the country
are caring for someone a child a parent
a loved one or you work as a caregiver
on this national caregivers Day in the
midst of a pandemic that's even more
important to recognize the risk the
sacrifice and the love you put into
keeping the vulnerable safe Ross Lord
has the story of how one caregiver is
coping during these uncertain times it's
a challenging time for Carol Ann Alois
she's the caregiver for her husband Bill
you know it just adds to the isolation
being a caregiver you're isolated
already maybe because people don't
really understand the physical and
emotional stress that you're under
another layer to it she's among millions
of Canadians caring for loved ones with
long-term health problems or
disabilities in their homes often
caregivers do exhausting work that puts
them at greater risk of medical problems
and new research in Ontario shows only
half of family caregivers have a
contingency plan for kovat 19 one of the
strategies that we recommend is
expanding your circle of care looking at
who could step in and provide support if
you need it to self isolate and not
provide the care that you would normally
provide as a caregiver they're
developing an online portal where people
can look for or offer help with things
like groceries and prescription pickup
Carol Ann says she's less exhausted
physically since bill recovered from a
series of ankle surgeries that left him
eMobile their biggest priority she says
is the health of their children and
grandchildren as for their own health
they have a plan for one or the other to
self isolate in their home if needed but
that only goes so far when both have
vulnerable immune systems it's a concern
for both of us if either of us gets it
and especially if we pass it to the
other person like what happens if we
both get it mine I can't even imagine
waiting out the pandemic with care loss
Lourdes global news and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen with Easter just around the
corner we thought you might be wondering
about the status of
Easter Bunny well not to worry is the
east of money coming oh we're making the
Easter Bunny and essential service
Ontario's premier is one of many
political leaders who have declared the
Easter Bunny's work and essential
service and we're all happy about that
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye bye
you